don't admit it grab your umbrella it's a
total shift storm on Capitol Hill the
Russia gate hoaxer and fangfang's BFF
Eric swallow are freaking out after
Kevin McCarthy kicked him off the Intel
committee the speaker also threatening
to call a vote to remove ilhan Omar from
house Foreign Affairs wouldn't that be a
shame Kevin McCarthy showing his boss
while making the announcement watch
those voters elected shift even though
he lied those voters elected swallow
even though he liked the American public
too so you know what I'll respect his
voters too and they'll serve on
committees but they will not serve on a
place that has National Security
relevance because Integrity matters to
me yes but the Three Stooges aren't
going down without some whining by
complaining to anybody in the
sympathetic media who will listen
the cardinal sin appears to be that I
led the impeachment of his master in
Mar-A-Lago do they want to come back for
vengeance and take me off my committees
to punch me in my case it's purely
political Vengeance I think he'll regret
giving all three of us more time on our
hands it's not going to stop me at all
he's taking one of the most precious
pieces of glassware in the Congressional
cabinet and smashing it it is about
revenge it's about the appeasing the
former president it was a fundraising
gimmick on the one hand but more
seriously this is Kim McCarthy's way of
getting and keeping the votes he needs
to be speaker so Schiff thinks it's a
fundraising gimmick but lo and behold
he's already trying to cash in by
posting this fundraising tweet himself
meanwhile you can probably guess who the
media is rooting for in this little spat
this isn't good for America
for our politics this isn't good for
congress but it's kind of like you know
a kid putting their hand on the hot
stove there is no legitimate reason to
keep shift or swallow off the
intelligence committee McCarthy has a
lot of power and as Speaker that power
really trumps whatever the tradition may
be it certainly looks like retribution
by the speaker is it yeah Andrew it
certainly appears that way
okay well we're all safer that these two
guys are not on the house Intel
committee so I think that's a good thing
the media doesn't really buy that though
well this feels very cut and dried to me
and Kevin McCarthy said all along if he
were to become speaker that this was
what was going to happen actually I'm
pretty sure that if anybody had become
speaker on the Republican side that this
was going to happen this was something
that when you know the reporters or
Andrea Mitchell says this seems like
retribution I was like well do you just
conveniently forget what happened to the
pre in the previous Congress and where
the Republicans said if you do this to
our members even we might even though we
disagree with what they said
we think that was reprehensible but if
you take them off committees that's
going to happen to you as well to me
it's very cut and dried and Schiff he's
already raising money off of this
remember I said he's he's running for
Senate in California so this is a gift
to him and that he can continue to go
out raise money get on TV you can always
say like oh I'm it's I'm so hard done by
the bottom line here is that Republicans
can allow themselves to be
swayed by just what the media is going
to say about them just be principled
keep your promise and move forward
they're not saying that they can't be on
all sorts of other committees they could
be on lots of other committees just not
ones with National Security information
it's a very important committee I mean
that's where you get briefed on all of
America's top secrets and they abused
that yeah especially Schiff if this were
just a committee that dealt with roads
or nutrition or exercise it's we're
going to examine America's issues with
exercise leave them on but this
committee has the word intelligence in
it right so right there there's a
violation them they should not be in a
committee with the word intelligence
that's like a man using a woman's
bathroom just by saying he's a woman
they're identifying as intelligent when
in fact they are morons uh I believe
they should replace Schiff with George
Santos just for fun but
um there's you know there's no proof
that they shouldn't be kicked off shift
is the political equivalent of a
Nigerian prince email right he initiates
a scam he's the one that initiates the
Russian collusion scam tells you that
you have some that he has something but
he can't show you it just like the
Nigerian scam I have I have a will
that's bequeathing me 100 million
dollars you can't see it but I can see
it that's what he did with collusion
right oh is there evidence when they ask
some of those evidence it goes oh yeah
there's evidence
uh and you'll see it shortly he never
had it so the evidence never
materialized because it never existed so
I don't think he has that these are
people these are like people that
graduated from high school that are
hanging around in the parking lot go
home it's really it's creeping everybody
out go find some other stuff to do it's
not the end of the world you know you
know you'll find something better to do
Eric and shave really it doesn't look
good with a beard or at least that kind
of beard I never give the Nigerian
princess any money because they use the
word bequeathed yeah no Banker uses that
that is the red flag for me I want to
show you once the White House Press
Secretary Judge Jeanine here's kjp today
we'll say that um
it comes to that committee it should not
be politicized it should be independent
and and again those Congressional
members bring a lot of expertise uh to
that committee and I'll leave it there
and she'll leave it there a lot of
expertise okay first of all let me make
this really simple the Democrats did it
to the Republicans and the Republicans
said don't do this it's going to
establish a president don't do it it's
not a good precedent so the Republicans
do it but the difference is the
Republicans have cause and let me tell
you what the cause is swalwell belongs
nowhere near an intelligence committee
and we talked about this yesterday and
the fact that McCarthy said he couldn't
get security clearance in the private
sector or in the government now
according to the director the dcid which
is director of Central Intelligence
directive 114. uh continuing security
clearance uh is when you have or they
question your whether you you should
have it is if you are connected to
another country I'm going to skip that
one let me do this foreign influence
okay conditions that signal security
concerns that are disqualifying include
relatives cohabitants or Associates who
are connected with any foreign
government sharing living quarters with
a person or persons regardless of their
citizen status and when there is an
affection or an obligation between the
individual and in this case the
congressman affection so this dcid says
basically that small well shouldn't be
anywhere near that intelligence
committee these are the guidelines that
they use so he doesn't have the right to
be on that committee and neither does
shift because he's lied for the last
four years and you know what everybody's
raising money off it is what they always
do but small world's a danger he had a
relationship with a with a Chinese Spy
Who fled the country as soon as they
identified her as a spy she was working
in his office she put an intern in his
office she raised money for him and they
are shown together in in party
situations where the two of them
together and Breitbart has confirmed
that they were in a relationship
that's enough do you have any special
codes that you want to cite the judge
didn't send many of the any me in any of
those kind of papers for me to look at
look I said yesterday I don't like
eighth grade politics and I think uh you
did it now I'm going to do it now look
when I was in seventh eighth and Ninth
Grade that's what we did but I think you
have to be growing up about these things
democrats should not have done it to
Republicans Republicans I shouldn't do
it to them but we are where we are I
think the swallow matter has more uh
more standing in my mind than than the
the the ship matter because if we want
to just push people off committees
because we don't like them or they were
wrong about a policy matter again as I
said yesterday no one would sit on a
committee if swallow isn't an
intelligence threat or a security threat
they should have raised this in the last
Congress because he remained on the
committee and these matters that the
judge is Raising or insinuating in the
majority
hear me I guess if you believe someone
is a security threat I don't care who
you are you should you could have we
said he was but we're not but judge here
I'm saying Mr Mr uh McCarthy and Mr
scalise and others should have gone to
the intelligence agency gone to the
Department of Justice and said we have
information
I went to McCarthy and Polo
pollution but they never charged him or
convicted I'm not he doesn't have to be
charged under the guidelines dcid 114.
he doesn't have to be charged he's not
qualified here's here's the case I I'm
not I'm not defending necessarily or
supporting him I'm just saying of the
two he seems to be the one where there
is a greater case for what we're saying
shift just because you don't like him or
you don't believe what he did before was
the right thing to do that's your
opinion I have a different opinion and
maybe others have a different opinion uh
about it but I don't I just don't think
they should do this you should have not
done it before we are where we are I
hope this politics stops it is not a
great example for kids and it certainly
is not a great example for adults what
about the children that's what I was
thinking I know you were I was I was
channeling you I know I can feel the
channeling energy you don't always have
to turn the other chick Harold
[Laughter]
Brett Baer scoring a huge interview with
the top meta executive that's going to
break some very big news
so you are ending the suspension of
former president Trump on Facebook and
Instagram
why are you doing that now and explain
what's behind it we're confirming that
if he wants to he can in the coming
weeks he can use Facebook uh in
Instagram again
um I mean of course there are guard
rails There Are Rules he's got to play
by the the rules
Trump's back don't miss special report
after the five hi winner Brian Kilmeade
I want you to do me a favor I want you
to click to subscribe to the Fox News
YouTube page this is the only way that I
know for sure that you're not going to
miss any great commentary any great news
bites any great interviews coming your
way on Fox you can get it all here on
YouTube so subscribe right now